first of all happy Hanukah happy Hanukah
today is the second day of Hanukkah yes
and as per Jewish tradition the second
day of Hanukkah celebrates the miracle
of a Democrat being elected in Alabama
I love those ancient traditions yeah of
course everybody knows now Doug Jones
beat Roy Moore yeah Roy Moore experts
say this is what they're saying today
experts say Roy Moore lost the election
due to write-in candidates people that
wrote it yeah due to write-in candidates
Moore was furious and said once again I
am done in by my old enemy literacy now
seriously seriously Moore is really
furious he hasn't been this angry since
they cancelled Hannah Montana so
[Applause]
yeah yeah I'll take was our booze or
whatever bring them all out there just
make some noise this makes it home awake
yeah I have a nice I have a nice
celebrity story a lot of people have
sort of negative celebrity stories not
this guy
no I got dozens of them I know you do
yeah but don't tell him though all right
nice celebrity story it's come out that
George Clooney gave 14 of his best
friends 1 million dollars each yeah your
nose pissed right now George Clooney's
15
and I'm done and this is one guy what
the hell happened I was there for you
like I said yesterday was a big special
election in Alabama ended up in an upset
for one more you can kind of see how
unexpected
the result was from war and how much it
affected him you can really see this for
example here's footage of Roy Moore
yesterday riding his horse sassy back
home after voting you can see he's
really happy
take a look he's really in a good mood
yeah well then he had a really rough
night didn't win here he is earlier
today leaving his home you can tell
that is so stupid but I love it
you